if turning the gender clock back to the
1950s wasn't far enough for me and my
cushion tush I have a date with another
popular school one that draws its
inspiration from caveman times
valentinovich choose our Nina's class
encourages men and women to tap into
their primordial instincts by summoning
up the inner Flintstone we search the
search it in our cop15 this paralysis
and yak now put it on convertibility
Slavonic if a cousin reads it you are
strong and with you and I believe in
your cause every time you're my king and
the most powerful man in my life and I
know you're that's unbelievable and it
does my ringtone
can you can you record this for me later
I need to listen to this every morning I
think I wake up to this inside woken
from a slumber of Western egalitarian
ISM my inner Fred Flintstone began to
stir a chance
like an epic double-oh-seven fight scene
a British hero fends off the Russian
villain from reaching the beautiful
woman maybe more mr. bean this is flat
bean cape on again yeah yeah exactly
because it's nature of power inside of
your body yes always there how you feel
I feel like a new man and how do you
feel strong inside of you and you become
more strong man yeah I like it you like
it yeah so so should we get married yeah
that's what the course is isn't it and
what could be more manly than draping an
awkward arm around a girl who it turns
out already had a boyfriend
[Music]